if I know the story correctly
you go to a comedy club and the guy and
it was in maybe Texas and the guy
working the comedy club or booking it is
Steve Harvey yes and that's how you guys
met yes so so you went there and you
basically said can I get up on on stage
and you they said you have to go talk to
Steve Harvey yeah it was uh actually I
was in Dallas to do a different club and
when I got there uh I was the opening
act and it was a new ownership and he
was like well I don't I don't use you
know uh non-local opening act sorry and
I was like what like bro I drove 10
hours I was supposed to you know I was
supposed to make 350 for 19 or 17 shows
I don't know how you know they would
just abused you back then come do 11 do
14 shows and we'll give you three
hundred dollars
all right thank you you know half a
milkshake yeah yeah don't ask where the
other half went no do not is this been
opened hey none of your business
want it or not all right I'm thirsty but
uh but but Steve was starting his own
little comedy night at a at a bar club
kind of situation and he had had a
couple of weeks where he was killing it
I knew knew of him he was like the big
name of a comedians that was out and so
I went there and you know there was one
comedian that that introduced us you
know just via like hey you need to hear
about this guy and he told me about
Steve so I was like yo I know this guy
and he was like oh yeah yeah come on in
and it just so happens that the
headliner that week was not doing well
and so he was like you think you can
handle this crowd and he said I'm gonna
put you up on stage to do five minutes
and so I went up and I killed it and he
just told me if I come back every night
if this guy doesn't do well I'm gonna
put you on stage and so that's I never
really hoped for somebody to do bad but
man you talking about Juju I like come
like every night and just look at that
guy like
[Laughter]
I like to think I'm a good person but
we've all been in those situations we're
like please
but it was it was one of those
situations where Steve and I became very
close from that and because he I ended
up going and doing well he gave me a
couple hundred bucks to get home and
then they brought me back the headline
like a few months later and so and then
our relationship started from there so
we just ended up being friends and you
guys have been tight for ever since ever
since that was that was probably late
90s is it true you guys vacation
together yoga what's that like yeah
what's it like when YouTube just hang
out on a beach
well you know Steve is definitely became
a super fashion person now so now it's
like too much anxiety of me trying to
figure out what my outfits are going to
be
they used to be just like cool man
buddies but like now he's like become
some Fashion Icon and so like like I
can't even be near him without like
having my drip right like I'm like so
it's like the whole time before the
vacation it's like okay because these
shorts go with that what shoes should I
I'm not gonna go
also you're looking out the window with
binoculars what's he wearing what's he
wearing I don't want to show up at
dinner I don't want to Clash I don't
want to match is that is that a cable is
he
is that a flowy Cape what is going on
hey Sona think of all the amazing things
in life that are expressions of just you
yeah I mean like the chocolate that you
had on your face when you came in
because you just ate that what was it
you were eating I was eating a giant
cookie giant cookie yeah and that's so
Sona okay or that song you stream over
and over again it's just so you what's
that song For You Twinkle Twinkle Little
Star yeah that is for my boys no no
still it's nice okay or you know that
podcast that comedy podcast you just
gotta listen to yeah Conan O'Brien needs
a friend is that what you listen to in
your spare time yeah I love it
everything that makes you you makes all
the difference State Farm believes
Insurance should work the same way your
plan your coverage selections can be
personalized by you and only you that's
cool I shouldn't shout but this is how
strongly I feel about it you go to
choose a plan you want by picking the
options that fit you like choosing to
bundle your home and auto policies is
what the State Farm personal price plan
is all about getting the coverage you
want at an affordable price just for you
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state options
selected by customers availability and
eligibility may vary you know he he he's
he can gamble too and I'm not much of a
gambler but usually whenever I'm
gambling with Steve I make money so
that's the only time that I like to kind
of go because he'll be like you know he
plays cards and and he'll show me like
do this do this and I'm like all right
oh cool I just won but I would never do
it on my own like I'm not a I'm not a
gambler I'm not either but if I'm around
someone I just tell them please tell me
what to do yeah exactly and if it goes
badly I have someone to hate which makes
it work out yeah I like had it I had
some the last trip we were in the
Bahamas together and I actually when I
was leaving I had like maybe like three
thousand dollars worth of chips in my
pocket and totally forgot so it was like
what did I do with this so I look like a
big timer because I was just like giving
people chips on the way out you know you
know man thanks bro except for the bags
my man take that
my friend is just a chip but take it
over there
has he uh I I would think the one thing
I think of when I when I Steve see Steve
now it's always Family Feud I see him
doing Family Feud and and the one thing
I worry about is that doing a gig like
that over and over and over again would
just would like start to get to your
mind you know what I mean I worry
sometimes like it when you talk to
people yeah exactly I don't know that
just over and over and over again doing
the Family Feud would would change top
five appetizers before your order
buffalo wings
number two
french fries french fries
Caesar salad
then you give him one that clearly
disappoints him yeah stewed tomatoes
[Laughter]
you know he's doing that when he you
know if you wake him up at three in the
morning that's what everybody wakes up
yeah
you can't you can't answer my question
without it being phrase like
yeah that's probably so true and they do
a lot of them at once too that's the
other thing like when they shoot those
shows that's how they deal with them
like so so you're right I think in that
period of time it just got to be in your
head because you're doing like a hundred
sometimes they do like 106 shows in a
matter of like three months so just day
every day like popping them off like bro
right and then change suit and act like
okay now it's Christmas time even though
you're shooting it in July you know you
just keep going and going and going
exactly we should do the podcast that
way
[Music]
the name
seems weird it seems lazy with coffee is
opposite when you look at it latte you
know got it supposed to get me up okay
get the out of here who's next
director murder Herzog get in here he's
Madness this is insanity shut up burner
ah